hey guys so we actually tried making
this public yesterday but it did get
blocked worldwide
so we had to make the little oval shape
around it so it could be seen publicly
and had to work around some of the music
but for the most of it it's pretty good
still still enjoyable still enjoyable
reaction
what's happening reject nation greg and
john here we are going to watch
two clips from godzilla versus kong
first one is called
kong try to break barrier and then the
other one is he
told me these are two clips that were
sent our way excited to check this
out hopefully we can get these up on
youtube
because last time there was a bit of a
problem the most recent when we covered
it
managed to get that strike removed but i
had to compensate in a lot of ways to
get it up here
so uh yeah guys keep a lookout for
whenever we do end up covering it gonna
be honest y'all if i'm able to go watch
this in the theaters this week that's
how we're gonna watch it the first time
we watch it if not
then we'll do a movie reaction either
way he'll get some kind of review from
us
let's swing an action
seen that move before
interesting
eerie oh i love that transitioning to
her pov
[Music]
i get it
[Music]
no they already got him no
gotcha oh damn
oh that's heartbreaking oh [ __ ]
we gotta talk about that after the next
clip automatically plays
we just dropped it into final cut
i love the transition of audio into her
perspective yeah into her pov that's
beautiful
[Music]
oh
wow
little one oh i hope she doesn't die
oh
[Music]
just the scale
oh
oh okay
he speaks sign language wow that's
cool that's a whole other flavor you
know
i have a feeling all the other human
characters are gonna be a big pile of
dog [ __ ]
i'm gonna love the crap out of this gia
girl maybe that's the key maybe you need
to throw in characters who don't speak
who have to communicate through
alternate means and who then can like
transform the tone of the movie through
their perspective
wow man both clips are about kong yeah
so they already have kong they already
got homeboy and they're already running
whatever
studies they gotta do on him this girl
that communicates them i mean it's
yet to be uncovered specifically what it
is unless they already
revealed the plot details but is she
someone from skull island
because i love the way that first clip
is done how they're playing the music
and um the lord knows if we're able to
keep the music in here
they're playing the music and it's
putting you back like oh are we
in the 60s 70s there if we go which was
a 77 vietnam war yeah so it's a 70s era
and so it's putting you back in there
and then breaking the barriers showing
like oh no they've already got
him and they're just playing my tricks
on him i wonder if that's like kind of
his introduction scene or
a later on moment showing how smart he
is where they capture him bring him over
throw him in here and he's like no this
ain't real i'm not buying this for a
second
they don't play this soundtrack on skull
island
not in our playlist what is going on
here
yeah because half of me expected that to
be like the reverse shot from skull
island of like oh that tree is going to
hit a
chopper oh no i'm going to reveal that
seems like a pretty big reveal too to
put in this trailer
i mean in adam wingard's uh ability to
transition into her pov i love that with
the auditory lapse like it doesn't go
completely mute
yeah but most of the sound super muffled
and bassy
yeah that was impressive i like kong i
love kong
i do i love him i really do so it it
pains me that
i'm really rooting for godzilla
i'm riding the same boat with you and
the same aircraft carrier with you
he's like i feel bad for him here and
you're not probably going to get these
kinds of scenes with godzilla
you know godzilla isn't going to be
finger booping anybody or sitting down
looking sad and whatnot
we'll see bryan cranston will come back
you know what's funny is
actually people constantly complain
about the human characters in fact the
early reactions came out
for this and they're exactly what you'd
expect
every other cutscene great action great
visuals monsters are cool
humans suck but everything around it's
great i'm like yeah what's new
well i'm like what i really cared about
the humans in
the godzilla 2014. i i did i really like
them a lot brian cranston and aaron
taylor johnson elizabeth olsen too on my
re-watch i really cared about all them
and um to me i haven't cared about a
human since gia showed up
i'm not gonna lie like that was great
and like even the interaction there
there's like so much
gravitas brought to kong in that moment
in the rain and the blue lighting and
and like this communication of we're
trying to help him like how are you
trying to help him exactly
you know but it sounds like you need him
and you want him to help you
yeah we're trying to help him help us
yeah i'm trying to do it doesn't seem
like
he needs you guys unless something did
go wrong at skull island but yeah i mean
there's a lot more to unpack i know some
a lot has gotten leaked already and i'm
trying to avoid that
so you know leave whatever comments you
want down you tell people not to
spoil stuff and then they do it anyway
yeah i'm sorry i'm just probably gonna
avoid the comments for the first
after the first 10 minutes yeah exactly
yeah yeah but in terms of like the
cinematography here and capturing the
scale of kong as well especially in that
final moment like
god damn that was something special oh
yeah well it's nice to just get a tonal
moment too to get hyped up for this
movie it's been so much of like monster
mayhem and now i'm like oh cool the
actual heart of the at least
monster characters is on display and
that's exciting too well they're what i
loved about these two clips that i
thought they brought which the other
ones
haven't brought and sometimes i felt
like king of the monsters was trying to
bring it
in certain elements is this sense of
wonder
yeah um like this sort of mystique here
like how does this child communicate
with this
giant animal you know this massive ape
so yeah it's beautiful stuff
excited for it but like i said if i'm
able to watch this experience it for my
first time
in a movie theater i'm taking that
option
okay i'm letting you know that right up
front from my personal experience
but we'll cover it in some way even if
we have to do like a movie commentary
track
you know like second time watching
watching here alright guys subscribe hit
that notification bell click that like
button
catch you guys soon